hi again this is a second video this
video that I'm making now I want to talk
to you I wanted to talk to you about
good choose the choice of good material
and Internet resources recently we've
seen human seeing an exponential
increase of communication systems and
learning tools the world wide net
worldwide net web is without a doubt the
most amazing invention of the last
century in terms of computation and
provides amazing resources for Glennis
learner it enables millions of people to
share permission freely and quickly
the huge drawback of this which is also
a matter of debate in scientific
literature especially psychology is that
it has radically changed the way we
approach and absorb information and
another not all of this goes towards a
very positive direction how many times
have you found ourselves talking to
friend on MSN chatting on skype and
talking and taking a look at some other
web sites at the same time multiple
operations carried out the same time
causes your brain scatter and disperse
the energy that normally puts to absorb
and elaborating information instead of
having just one big piece of consistent
information we have millions little
chunks with messages flying towards our
brain every day as a result of this a
lot of information enters your brain but
ago the other way the middle is retained
and
story starts with oh boy okay I've never
used Internet in order to learn foreign
language is not until now I've always
died go away by a collection of books in
the bookshop listen to some CDs some CDs
ride riot and then talk to natives
iconic rock at a later stage I use it
now to talk to people arms guys an event
with them and improve better my
languages but it's on the other noon
very recently and I won't still
convinced that learning language is
online at least for the first year where
I take another video quality is the key
word is not a good thing what I'm doing
now with Chinese and downloading some
very good books and study them very good
stuff very good books inside of offline
Internet will be an invaluable asset for
Chinese ones have learned it for some
time in the brain has got a good grasp
of it and a lost suppressed percept
internet-based information much more
efficiently internet to be dangerous for
a lot of reasons there are some videos
on YouTube showing videos whose guns
speak fluent German within six months it
reminds me of some cheap advertising
here in Italy how to get thin within
three weeks
the principle is more or less the same
in order to get good and less than
results while it needs to spend some
time money spent sometimes you have some
patience
there is a physiological time for
learning language are raining some time
to absorb it necessarily if you're in a
haste and spend three hours on your
computer
to get as much information as possible
you wear that Lennox vest but for me and
you're very likely to forget about
everything within a few months if you
have no more concept for that language
same goes for losing weight your life
you will like your body and more in size
lose 20 pounds in three weeks after
losing 20 pounds by simply not eating or
eating their little you are most likely
to gain what you've lost
a little bit later the principle is
exactly the same don't mean a Hank when
it comes to operations which
physiological you need sometimes great
and good results what I think is what
I'm not saying of course that internet
entrance incredible but one of the thing
is that you have to be to understand how
to use it properly what I think is what
is a wise way to use internet is to
download some good stuff because there
are incredible
websites for languages download some
good stuff and stick to it much better
to work very well on the limited
quantity of information and absorb it
well rather than jumping from side to
side and listen and disorderly to
multiple language sources spending a
number of reading say 30 pages of a book
in Russian in plain silence it's much
more effective than spending the same
amount of time from the internet just
jumping around you can download a page
and article Russian or whatever and
you've read it staying away from the
computer
whatever suggestion is to stay away from
grammar books there they are usually for
academic noting that you don't have to
look at them but if you are going to
engage in an academic if you want
there's usually for academic studies but
not for the natural
learner at least that this is class
opinion there are excellent courses out
there which explains sound grammar to
you but they don't working with grammar
they will see it as the key point hinge
of your study estimate is what I've used
to get intermediates in the last five
languages learning I've learned I
learned work I've been learning with
Dutch Swedish Russian Portuguese Chinese
as far as Daksha Swedish are concerned
use the teacher self-serious before I
did Eskimo which is a small but very
well-done book to get introduced to the
language the best course I've ever used
in my life is the old devastating force
which is used for both Spanish and
German the course is practically
identical for both the Eskimo series is
good to get the audience just in the
language you're learning because the way
is organized perfectly applies to how I
learn languages firstly and because it
is generally brilliantly written there
are medical notes in each lesson and
they organize that they are organized
according to the river DITA humans
principle which you lettin me repeating
things helps definitely a degree lesser
or it's right there are other option
courses of in Univ but I've never used
them and I can't really tell how good
they are like to spend this Michael
Mitchell Thomas for example or Pimsleur
but I've never
I can't tell how they are because I
don't know the most important point
though is that choosing good stuff for
learning lenses is important but the way
you use it the way you use this material
it's far more important and efficient
than the course itself the ethical
series generally tell the learner to
read the book and then go back and
review it again passive and reactive
face I do it slightly different because
I said in the video I read it and review
it by running the whole book while I
read that this means that progressively
I write again the whole book in both
languages so I sort the whole not absorb
everything but absorb most of it what I
because the problem is how much do we
absorb you know everybody where we were
all able to absorb a book hundred
percent of a book will be all really
linguist you know with it with the
problem that we retained heirloom of the
information that fluff the guest enters
our ear here and gets head from the
other year unfortunately what I wanted
to repeat it again is that this works
gives great importance to quality
quality is at the center of assorted
writing everything down there we
translating dialects into the target
language is incredibly efficient in the
mid and long term yes I'm serious
differently from the FDIC has a flaw the
second book with the serious generally
consists of two books finishes when the
real fun and the real learning start
after having finished the essence here
you are more or less the point where you
can you know enjoy the language be
prepared they train your brain to absorb
the language vitamins at that point once
you finish the decimals here is you're
ready to watch movies or a talk to
people you read but that's that's a
that's a that's a shame because it would
like the absolute ears to be four or
five six books but they're just sooo a
but at this point that that said you
have to add quantity to quality the
working done so far it's absorb silence
by listening and by absorbing grammar
for re translating dadada this kind of a
grammar shattering in the sense that we
need when you retranslate think you are
shadowing if you were reproducing the
the tact and you're learning the
structure but without using the grammar
which is amazing and you know the
grammar of re translating the dialects
which make up the fabric
Kathlyn language and whereas you having
feel read articles about specific topics
and generally collect a broad vocabulary
but at this point you can start watch
movies best with subtitles in that
language and you can take some knows
here there they did when watching him
you can read newspapers if you can use a
highlighter and cues in it he's an
highlighter it's very helpful and some
simple books needless to say after six
and eight months of passion or or any
other course if you pray you're bringing
up you are more more than ready to get
by and that breaking Congress to do in a
rhythmic conversation with with a make
it quick at least as far as European
lenses are concerned as well as an easy
oral conversation on this guy don't
start doing this though if you don't
feel confident enough because it can
lead to frustration and frustration
should definitely be bad from the
learning problems and above all if
you're looking for a native speaker to
talk to try and find a nice and
encouraging first human resources are
and will always be the best ways to
improve languages no matter what
technology will create in your cigar
thank you so much look University to
tell